so why is this quality so terrible well
I'll tell you why I'm on vacation right
now and I took the time out of my
vacation at Universal Studios Florida to
go see focus tonight because I'm
dedicated to you guys this is what I do
I love doing this and I want to make
sure that I get a new review for you
this weekend despite the fact that I'm
currently on vacation so I apologize for
the lesser quality of this video I do
have my microphone with me though so the
audio will at least be nice and crisp
and I also apologize for the shortness
of this review but hey I'm on vacation
so it cut me some slack at least got a
nice background for you right so focus
stars Will Smith and Margot Robbie and
this movies about con men a con man
training a con woman to be a better con
woman and of course they eventually fall
for each other or do they are they
conning each other the entire time who
knows because these guys are going back
and forth so much that the story can
become a little bit convoluted at times
but you know what I really enjoyed this
movie surprisingly because I saw the
trailer for this movie and I was like
I'm not looking forward to this Will
Smith lately has not been impressing me
at all but hey at least his kids aren't
in this one but I would say this is
actually one of his better movies of
recent years in fact I really enjoyed
this movie purely based on the stars
chemistry their charisma the dialogue
and how good this movie looked this
movie has excellent cinematography and
lighting I love the look of this film it
also has a very original structure it
doesn't feel like your typical first
second and third act structure does feel
very original
it feels very unique in that way and so
the movie kept me on my toes because you
think the movie is going in a certain
way but eventually subverts that and not
just because it's a con man movie and
there's all kinds of weird stuff
happening back and forth but it's
because of the way the film is
structured it was very very different
and I liked that as for issues with the
movie I would say that the emotional
core of the movie is really broken at
times because it's hard to really latch
on to some of these characters because
you never really know exactly what
they're thinking there's pluses and
minuses to the twisty-turny script but
for the most part it's a plus I actually
really had a lot of fun with focus it's
sort of like a strange twisty Ocean's
eleven with a little
more drama thrown in and a little bit
less fun silly stuff but that fun stuff
is still there and Will Smith and Margot
Robbie are excellent in this movie they
were very well together and they have
very compelling characters I would
recommend seeing focus it's a lot better
than I thought it was going to be and
I'm going to be a focus of be guys
thanks a lot for watching and once again
I apologize for the briefness of this
review for the lesser quality this is
gonna be the only video like this I have
a whole bunch of other videos ready for
you including a Batman and Robin
hilarious 'ti with John flicking jerk or
the flick picked that's 42 minutes long
that's gonna go up on Sunday look
forward to that guys and I'm gonna go
enjoy my vacation now so thanks for
watching and if you liked this you can
click right here and get stubborn eyes